Wesley welcome back to the show a quiet
day at the office for you the strategy
seems to have been uh clear uh tell us a
bit about today's game tell us a bit
about your estim estimation about your
performance at this
Championship well thank you guys it's
nice to be back but first I'd like to
say a big congratulation to Fabian
Carana for winning his third us Chess
Championship it was a very well-deserved
Victory I he could have won an extra
more game I actually but uh yeah he's
he's been playing really really well
recently he also almost won Norway he
won
Romania um and he's also playing very
well on speed on faster time controls
which I'm not sure how you do that you
do you play well but uh yeah uh well the
third Victory and uh I hope he I hope he
keeps it up uh especially for next
year's Olympia maybe we can finally win
another gold medal absolutely yeah big
Olympiad is coming up but tell us about
your play that's the plan that's the
plan well my play has been subpar that's
why I didn't feel like playing today
considering the way that he's been
playing and the way that I've been
playing the way uh the way that I've
been playing in the last few months was
not entirely what I was hoping for and
it didn't exactly go my way so the world
cup I had like a mental breakdown so I'm
still reeling from that uh I'm still
recovering
um after the World Cup I played in the
world team championship and my teammates
pretty much carried me I scored
50% uh so it's clear that uh you know I
need to work harder on my chest I need
to set things right uh the the plus two
performance in this tournament is very
good considering all things but I wasn't
especially pleased with my play I
thought I was making bad decisions here
and there like small positional
decisions uh yesterday against Hans nean
I guess if I played Knight B7 incept
Queen D6 maybe I had some chances you
know maybe it was the last chance to try
to fight for the tournament
Victory but uh it is uh it is what it is
and uh right now at least I get three
weeks of
relaxation and uh
I'll still try to you know work on my
chest and try to try to recover but
coming before terment I knew that the US
Championship was going to be tough this
is my ninth year and uh as I said from
the beginning I believe the US
Championship is the toughest Tournament
of the Year considering that uh
everyone's very well prepared and you're
playing against uh young people so so
and then I can't really complain but uh
I have to I have to to play play better
CH many players um not many at your
level but many players throughout the
world experience this type of slumps in
their form in their shape how do you
address that as an elite competitor how
do you do
it well I guess you just live your life
uh a day at a time uh you keep uh you
keep working you know take it easy if
it's not meant to be it's not meant to
be uh just uh I just try to be happy and
relaxed try to put in my work every day
try to put in a few hours a couple hours
at least of Chess work every day and
then uh and then see what happens after
all that's all you can do no one knows
the future what the future holds but I
do hope Fabian becomes a world champion
one day but no one knows so I mean you
just got to uh keep working taking it uh
taking it easy you know enjoy life
um yeah I I guess uh that's uh pretty
much but also my mom kept telling me
that chess has
changed these days compared to a decade
ago there's a lot more faster time
controls there's a lot more online chess
there's a
bullet uh and I can't really
blame people for it happening because
due to advancement of
technology not everyone wants to watch a
classical game like I'm not going to sit
in front of computer and watch a 4our
game it's like watching paint dry I look
at the critical moment I look at the
critical moment and uh we try to make it
a bit more exciting W yeah yeah yeah
yeah for sure yeah you yeah you you you
know you you three you three keep it
going but you know yeah has a lot of
experience and you're gaining a lot but
uh okay no no no no offense intended but
I love it but Bish an told Bish an told
me in Amsterdam that people don't even
watch entire games nowadays they just
watch clips of the games so uh it is
what it is but I think uh I think if
there's only one time control in chess
it'll be easier for me to focus on that
but nowadays you like the last years
I've been earning as much money from
fast time controls as classical mhm so
you have to be very good at both and I
find that a bit a bit uh uneasy but uh
we're we're trying our best so your
training in Rapid sometimes takes away
from your training in classical that's
definitely a balancing act Wesley thank
you very much for your good performance
in this event and for your entertaining
interviews as well guys any questions
for yeah very very quick very very quick
question for you Wesley um not talking
about your performance uh but I always
like these US championships in terms of
the new talents uh that come and the
debut of Mishra for me has been a real
Revelation he's played here in my
estimation extremely successfully and
yeah maturely uh your your your your
take sitting across the board from
Mishra what
how does it feel for from from your
perspective well yeah for sure I mean
during the last few years the United
States is a big country and uh we have a
lot of great amazing talents that come
up the scene a m sure is clearly
exceptional he's very talented but he's
also you know I guess hardworking and
very intense yeah you know he's father
sure has big plans for him uh yeah I
think he's you know he's doing very very
well he's got a bright future ahead of
him uh there are a lot of questions that
need to be answered mostly you know is
he willing to keep this up or is he does
he want to be become a professional
chess player right uh because when
you're a teenager like you're very
focused on chess you know you're you're
very motivated you're doing well but we
don't know yet what happens uh in the
future but uh uh right now the future
looks
you know really bright for him I predict
he'll reach 2700 soon one day MH uh if
things keep up um but uh it's it's nice
to see that we have all this amazing
talents come up here and there he's not
an easy opponent to to play with uh he's
got a lot of
strength and uh he's you know there's
still room for improvement but I'm sure
that uh I'm sure that he can do it I I
think St Louis is doing a good job in
cultivating younger players also us
chess and also we have the Sam for
Fellowship abs for people under the age
of
26 so I guess my message to me sure just
keep doing what he's doing you know
he'll keep improving he'll he'll get
there at at least we have a we have a
very young teenager to to challenge the
the the the Indian Prodigy from other
side continent wle on your performance
thank you for the Fighting Chess it
looks like you're really respectful of
all the other players and appreciative
thank you for that as well yeah for sure
I mean after I realized that I couldn't
beat under Tang there's no e opponent in
the US Championship all right thank you
Wesley thanks and indeed Christian tell
us